worked
there you go hi there this is chip davis
i'm in nebraska right now it's like 65
degrees not a cloud in the sky
i got all my windows open today chip is
most well known for his musical group
mannheim steamroller
which has made dozens of chart-topping
christmas albums
but in the 1970s he was known for
something completely different
chip was right out of college living in
nebraska and writing commercial jingles
for an
advertising agency my clients they were
like
black and decker drills and greyhound
bus and
continental and i wrote somewhere in the
vicinity of 2000
jingles and he wasn't that plugged into
the world of pop music
i didn't really know what some of the
styles were i remember the first time i
got
asked to write some r b i didn't even
know what r b stood for
i thought that was a restaurant in
downtown omaha
when i was with the ad agency i said all
right any type of music but don't ask me
direct country because i don't know
anything about it
this is where things get interesting by
1976
his country song was number one on the
billboard charts
like holy cow how'd that happen this
song
is what happened this here's a rubber
duck
you got a copy on me big fan come on
this
is convoy a song chip davis produced
with his writing partner bill freeze
a creative director at the ad agency he
worked for its lyrics captured a
fictional conversation between two truck
drivers across cb radio
and it was wildly popular probably the
largest record
that i created it was the number one
song in the us and canada
and charted across europe it was so huge
that
hollywood made an entire film based on
it
i mean it was it was a big deal it's a
strange song to listen to
45 years later to many its lyrics might
not even make sense
what's a bear in the air or a suicide
jockey
why is he called rubber duck but this
song is a time capsule
from a brief era when truck drivers were
full heroes
and the country music that soundtracked
their lives topped the charts
this is the story of trucker country
country music has always dealt with sort
of issues of
wanderlust and travel that's nate gibson
he's a country music scholar
those sort of played out in the in the
30s and 40s
through imagery of the western frontier
cowboy imagery
and train songs
there have always been labor songs about
american
occupational heroes we we have lumbermen
railroad men
[Music]
but as travel and work shifted to roads
and automobiles
so did the characters country music
focused on truck drivers became
country's new folk heroes
the first trucker hit in 1939 was cliff
brunner doing truck drivers blues
[Music]
throughout the 40s there are scattered
remnants of truck songs that sort of
cut through the masses but things
changed dramatically in 1956
when president eisenhower unveiled a
plan to revamp the interstate highway
system
this is the american dream of freedom
on wheels an automotive age
traveling on time-saving super highways
these interconnected highways allowed
people to travel long distances more
easily
and it created thousands of new jobs
especially in the long-haul trucking
industry
and with that a new market for country
music opened up
truckers spent the majority of their day
and night staring down an open highway
it was a lonely profession and often the
only entertainment they had was the
music at roadside cafes
when you went to a truck stop you could
always play songs on the jukebox
and the music on the radio it's
important to know they're really two
major types of radio stations in the
united states
at in the 1960s and 70s that's travis
steimling he's a country music scholar
there are am stations that can only
broadcast during the daytime
and then their am stations that can
broadcast overnight
these nighttime stations were really
unique because they had such little
signal interference they could travel
much longer distances than your typical
radio range
they would cater often to the truck
drivers who were on the road
uh you know all night long and they
would play these songs
songs about having pride and being a
trucker or
these weepers about being away from your
family and really just all sorts of
country music there's a flame farmer
you have six days on the road a massive
hit by dave dudley
my home towns are coming in if you think
i'm a happy you're right
six days on the road and am i gonna make
it home tonight
it draws a lot of what we call the
bakersfield sound and this is really
twangy country music
with electric instruments telecaster
guitars
lots of high frequency sounds sharp
attacks on the notes
it's the kind of music that could keep
you awake if you were driving a
long-haul trip across the country
six days on the road climbed to number
two on the country charts right
alongside johnny cash's
classic ring of fire and buck owens act
naturally
and it kicked off what many music
scholars consider the golden age of
trucker country music
six days
i would consider the golden age of
trucker country between 1963 and 1966
not only were individual artists
releasing singles and albums
but record labels were making
compilation albums centered around the
trucking theme
especially star day records they put out
their first
trucker specific album in 1963 and it
sold so well that every artist who came
into the studio
after that they would say hey this
session's great but can you add a
country music song about truck driving
to that
this time period saw the release of
classic trucker songs
like tombstone every mile if they buried
all the truckers
lost in them woods there'd be a
tombstone
every mile roll truck roll
[Music]
tons of steel and if you were paying
attention to
the lyrics you might have noticed
something many of these songs were
real downers red sovine this guy
was an artist known for dialing up the
sadness factor to attend
they called him the syrup sopper because
he was promoted by a syrup company on
the hayride but also
his songs were so syrupy and sad and he
did these recitations about
finding his long lost son on the highway
and he lost track of him
that's the story line of his first big
trucker hit giddyup go
we got to talking shop and i said how'd
you come by the name on your truck giddy
up go
[Music]
well he said i got it from my pop and
then
the next song there's a school bus in
the middle of the road and a trucker
drives off a cliff to avoid
hitting the school bus full of children
on its side well
joe lost control went into his skin
and gave his life to save that bunch of
kids
and there at that crossroads was the end
of a line
for big joe and phantom 309 there's
something about like the the cab of a
truck being almost a safe place
to express yourself and these songs just
hit
every possible raw nerve truckers
weren't totally alone in their cabs
though
they had another special form of radio
where they could connect with each other
the cb citizens ban radio was a form of
short-range radio that was adopted by
truck drivers as their industry grew in
the 1960s
it was like a pre-internet public chat
room with its own insider lingo
for example you didn't go by your own
name but a made-up
handle my dad had a handle he was known
as the pumper
because he worked in the oil rigs pumped
oil my godfather was known as michelob
because that was his favorite beer in
this book the big dummy's guide to cb
radio
the author explains that truckers use
the cb to communicate
important things like traffic good
places to eat
and where to park their rig at night
citizen band radio was the great
connector along u.s highways
but in 1973 truckers harnessed the cb
in a way they hadn't before and in doing
so
became an inspiration for a new era of
trucker country music
the oil producing countries of the arab
world decided to use their oil as a
political weapon
the oil ban will continue against the
united states and the netherlands
because of their strong support of
israel in 1973
war broke out between israel and a
coalition of arab countries
and after the u.s provided military
support to israel
arab countries retaliated by holding
back oil supplies
the president said that all will have to
cooperate everybody is to have to do
some sacrificing the resulting oil
shortage affected nearly every aspect of
american life
but it was truck drivers who were really
hit hard
nixon signed a federal law lowering all
national highway speed limits to 55
miles per hour
it is now essential that we have
mandatory
and full compliance with this important
step
on a nationwide basis having had enough
truckers devised a plan to protest on
the highways
they am asked convoys of semi-trucks
which caused traffic jams that went on
for miles
and shut down some interstates
completely the protective convoy was to
move at 50 miles an hour with 500 feet
between trucks and a five-car police
escort
the fact that so many truckers managed
to come together was a feat
on its own and they pulled this off all
thanks to the cb radio
my riding partner bill had a cb radio
he was listening on this cb radio to all
of this stuff going on with the truckers
going down interstate 80
and he said man it sounds like a war
going on there fascinated by the lingo
bill and chips started to form an idea
we went about you know listening to it
and like thought
that's a song i bet we could turn that
into something i started it with the
military drum kings
breaker breaker there one night this
here's a rubber duck you got a copy on
me big fan come on
that's phil he adopted the stage name cw
mccall
you want to put that microbus in behind
that suicide jockey
yeah he's home dynamite and he needs all
the help he can hear and
if you don't know what that is the next
line tells you that guy's hauling
dynamite
a suicide jockey somebody's hauling
explosives or something that if you were
in an accident
the accident wouldn't kill you the
explosion would that's the thing about
these stories the way bill wrote the
lyrics was that they're so engaging
you could really picture it convoys
struck a nerve and it topped the charts
in 1976.
it also inspired dozens of more songs
that use the cb radio as a storytelling
device
[Music]
in the 70s you sort of establish your
authenticity and your credibility in
song
by being able to rattle off the cb lingo
a year after convoy was released none
other than the syrup sopper himself
released what is now considered one of
the saddest country music songs
ever and he used the cb radio to tell it
the old cb
was blaring away on channel one nine
when there came a little boy's voice on
the radio line
it's about a kid who's bound to a
wheelchair his dad was a truck driver
but
he died that had a wreck about a month
ago
he was trying to get home in a blind and
snow and so he
inherited his dad's cb and talks to
other truckers
spoiler alert all the truckers take the
off ramp into his community
and give him rides in the trucks this is
this weeper of a song
and every time i listen to it i just
bawl like a baby
the cb becomes the the mechanism through
which the story's told
country music and really all pop music
is always looking for a gimmick
and and the cb i think provided a good
one uh for a few years
convoy was a song that pushed trucker
and cb radio culture
into the mainstream but it wasn't
something totally new it tapped into a
long history of songs about working
class life
i think trucker country represents a
concerted effort on the part of some
songwriters to capture
the emotional experience of people who
are doing a working-class job
and that's something that goes way back
into
kind of the deep roots of american folk
[Music]
music
[Music]
you